there's an incredible group of animals
out there called the echinoderms they
can actually regenerate a lost body part
so a kind of derm essentially just means
spiny skin so derm like dermis so skin
and a chi know is sort of spiny so sort
of spiny skinned so it's sea urchins sea
cucumbers brittle stars and sea stars
they sort of all fall in this a kind of
derm group in general the padded domes
are filing with an incredible capacity
for regeneration if you're a sea
cucumber you know you don't move very
fast but if something's trying to get at
you and you got to give them something
interesting sea cucumbers will actually
eviscerate essentially throw up their
entire stomach can then regrow that
entire stomach tract if you don't have a
lot of abilities to make toxins if you
don't have an ability to make ink you
know you've got to find other ways to
escape take something like a brittle
start it can just drop off an arm in
order to escape and regrow a new one
there's connective tissue holding the
arm together and so when it sort of
senses this disturbance something
inherent says there's a problem we need
to escape and so they will fight that
arm tissue and just drop the arm and
swim away you have this initial healing
formation so it's called the blastema
that's sort of the new forming arm and
even over just a period of a few days
you can sort of begin to see it growing
and then it you can beginning to see its
segments so it's really a fascinating
process
[Music]
it doesn't necessarily make a lot of
sense in a way because it's very
energetically expensive to make new body
parts for whatever reason this group has
decided and this is the way we're gonna
evade predators it's really interesting
is this may actually lead to some long
live properties fact they've found sea
urchins that are almost 200 years old
are those animals just replacing lost
and damaged body parts how else is the
sea return going to live for 200 years
you know maybe something's happening
we're in a tissue deteriorates that can
regenerate that tissue we don't know
[Music]
[Music]